alors la promesse que nous tenons
aujourd'hui c'est de faire en sorte que
les français payent la réalité de leur
coût de
l'électricité c'est ce que j'ai porté au
niveau européen avec une négociation
historique où nous avons eu gain de
cause face notamment à à l'Allemagne qui
ne souhaitait pas
reconnaître l'énergie nucléaire comme
étant sur le même pied d'égalité que les
énergies renouvelables ça nous l'avons
fait le 17 octobre tout le monde nous
disait c'est impossible vous n'y
arriverez pas nous l'avons fait nous l'
on fait avec le président de la
République et la deuxième chose c'est la
négociation que j'ai mené avec EDF et et
Bruno Leem pour préparer la suite de ce
qu'on appelle laarine qui est une
régulation qui permet aujourd'hui aux
Français d'avoir une partie de leur
facture qui est fondé sur les coûts du
du nucléaire tout en étant exposé et on
l'a vu l'année dernière malheureusement
et de manière trop importante au prix du
marché avec cette nouvelle régulation ce
ne sera plus le cas puisque dès que le
Briis passera l'équivalent de 110 €
d'argent d'aujourd'hui alors nous
prélèverons sur EDF tout le complément
de recette que obtiendrait EDF dans dans
le paiement de ces factures et nous le
redonnerons aux consommateurs de façon à
ce qu'il ne cet élément d'augmentation
des prix ne pèse pas mais concrètement
sur leur fracture parce que là le prix
de l'électricité il a annoncé à la
hausse pour l'année prochaine alors
peut-être remettre les choses en
perspective nous on a très clairement
dit et je le redis la le prix de la
facture il doit évoluer en fonction de
la réalité des coûts de l'électricité de
notre mix électrique des coûts de notre
système nucléaire des coûts de de nos
réseaux c'est ce que nous faisons et
c'est ce que nous allons faire l'année
prochaine et on l'a dit très clairement
avec Bruno LEM les augmentations d les
rentes de facture c'est terminé au
maximum la facture augmentera de 10 % ça
c'est très clair sur l'augmentation du
1er février 2020 24 et après je vois que
le Sénat souhaite augmenter la fiscalité
sur la facture ce qui est un autre
propos c'est pas le cûp de l'électricité
en propre c'est la question de la
fiscalité ça c'est une discussion
budgétaire qui est en cours je ne suis
pas sûre qu'il faille comme le propose
le Sénat et comme l' voté le Sénat hier
augmenter de 20 % la fiscalité sur la
facture de l'électricité mais ça c'est
autre chose sans bouclier ça
augmenterait de 20 % le gouvernement
souhaite un bouclier pour le limiter à
10 % juste pour tout le monde mais le
Sénat le sén ou le bouclier
énergétique protégera au maximum à 10 %
ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
mettre plus de taxes sur
l'électricité voà le Sénat dit c'est
c'est pas grave que les les Français les
plus aisés payent leur facture 20 % de
plus en revanche il faut protéger les
plus modestes et faire des moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que c'est que les
Français les plus aisés je rappelle que
aujourd'hui le revenu médien en France
il est 1700 € par mois je ne suis pas
sûr qu'à 1700 € par mois vous soyez aisé
donc je pose cette question très
simplement je comprends la logique du
Sénat mais 20 % d'augmentation de la
facture ça me paraît draisonnable d'une
manière générale on peut dire qu'on est
rentré dans un monde où le tout le prix
de l'énergie les prix de l'énergie que
soit carburant gaz électricité et cetera
toutes sources d'énergie a augmenté et
ne baissera plus est-ce que nos
entreprises sont al je je vais
m'inscrire en faux contre ça regardez
les évolutions récentes le prix du
carburant est en train de baisser le
prix du gaz a baissé par par rapport à
l'année dernière et le prix de
l'électricité qui avait atteint des
sommets sur les marchés internationaux
est en train de
rerentrer la rivière rentre dans son lit
ce qui nous permet nous de lever le
bouclier électricité l'année prochaine
puisque nous n'aurons plus à compenser
l'écart entre le prix plafonné que nous
avons mis pour les Français et ce prix
délirant que nous devions payer sur les
marché il y a pas de il y a pas de
fatalité ça non il n'y a pas de fatalité
et puis surtout si on veut baisser le
prix de l'énergie en fait il faut agir
et c'est ce que nous faisons agir c'est
baisser notre consommation d'énergie et
c'est augmenter notre production
d'énergie décarbonée aujourd'hui nous
sommes dépendants à 99 % des importation
de pétrole 99 %. nous ne décidons pas
des prix du pétrole si nous voulons
demain ne plus avoir à subir les
augmentation du prix du carburant il
faut produire notre propre carburant en
quelque sorte notre propre carburant
c'est l'électricité l'électricité ça
coûte trois fois moins cher que le
pétrole dans un plein de voiture et ce
que nous portons avec le gouvernement le
président de la République et la
premierre ministre c'est d'avoir des
solutions d'accès à des voitures
électriques qui soient réellement à des
prix à la portée du portefeuille des
Français moyens et des Français modestes
avec le bonus écologique que je souhaite
renforcer avec la prime à la conversion
ou avec le dispositif de leasing à 100
€. ça ce sont des solutions concrètes et
une fois que les Français seront équipés
de ces voitures derrière ils
économiseront du carburant puisque vous
savez que par année d'utilisation d'une
voiture électrique je parle d'une petite
voiture électrique un modèle type C3 ou
R5 c'est à peu près 1000 à 1200 €
d'économie chaque année c'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait pour les
Français